Metro Police arresting a man not for his
first or even his fourth DUI but his
10th thank you for joining us at six I'm
Brian Loftus I'm Denise Valdez eight
news now investigator David charns
uncovering what led up to the man's
arrest and how he was able to even have
a car David joining us live from Metro
headquarters near MLK and Alta David
well the number is simply shocking these
documents we received today from Metro
Police show that this 62 year old man
had nine prior DUIs his latest making it
10.
John Grant's 10th DUI arrest happened
Monday just before midnight and the
historic West Side documents say a metro
police officer heard a noise finding
Grant next to a motorcycle in quote
attempting to stand up but struggling to
keep his balance the officer writing
Grant said he slipped on liquid in the
road but police say the road was dry
records they use now investigators
obtained show Grant's record for DUI
spans decades with his first recorded in
1998. in his 2004 DUI arrest at that
point his fourth police say they found a
quote glass with ice which had the odor
of an alcoholic beverage sitting in the
front console on the vehicle where Grant
was seated in 2008 his seventh Grant was
drunk with no license and an open 24
ounce beer in his car we have a lot of
repeat offenders but it is a small
subset of the population Thomas Moscow
is a former Clark County DUI prosecutor
most of those people an overwhelming
majority don't do DUI again
their experience with the system was
harrowing enough for them not to do it
now for that small percentage that do
reoffend we have a saying for them too
most of them will never stop in his last
DUI case from 2012 Grant served six
years in prison a judge ordering him to
have an interlock device installed on
his vehicle for at least a year upon his
release as to how he had a motorcycle
registered in his name a spokesperson
for the DMV says there's no state law
barring a person with a suspended or
revoked license from registering a
vehicle
now a judge said grants bail at 100
000 if he makes bail she told him not to
drive lava said Metro headquarters and
baby charms 8 news now now David this
man had a revoked license what happens
to people who get multiple DUIs at the
DMV
well it's not a court process that's a
DMV hearing process and what happens
under state law is if you get three DUIs
within a seven year span you're going to
have your license revoked for at least a
year obviously no one can control if
you're actually holding your physical
plastic license and you're supposed to
turn it in this gentleman had a Nevada
identification card we're told and
obviously Brian some people drive
whether or not they're told not to
yeah clearly David thank you for that
reporting